I mean she sells director Nielsen book
who compiled those figures so hey
dopamine to you 20 2017 slightly down on
last year well I think really if we look
at the longer-term trend we can see that
with we're in a really great position
compared with five years ago up an extra
thirty five million pounds worth of
spend that people are putting into their
books this year and it was really that
twenty sixteen was just a phenomenal
success loads happened in 2016 it was
the return of Harry Potter after ten
years we had a lot of the parity books
were doing really well hold the ladybird
ones oh yeah they were they were really
successful and so it's not so much that
we're down on last year which we are
it's a fact but really last year was so
phenomenal the fact that if we look at
the year-to-date values compared with
last year we're pretty much flat on
value which is great okay well let's
have a look at some of the Christmas
bestsellers number one is bad dad by
David Walliams which is sold more than
sixty thousand copies during the last
four weeks that's just ahead of Jamie
Oliver's latest cookery book and an old
Christmas Star Wars the Guinness Book of
Records I can tell you we're getting at
least one of those for my kids but in
case of watching a bet not say which one
but a cookery book a posh quiz book
which is also in the top ten and then
the latest Shades of Grey or whatever it
is bad sex I mean what does this say
about the British book reading public
well I didn't think it shows how varied
it is I mean every year we have
children's fiction that does really well
which is great people are buying books
for children at Christmas and that's
what we want every year we have
nonfiction because nonfiction is a great
gift it's hardback it's colorful it's
lovely
but what's really encouraging for the
book markets this year we've got two
fiction titles in there you mentioned
darker so that's the return of EO James
title and also origin from Dan Brown so
these are both popular authors but the
fact that we've got fiction in the top
10 which is the first time for five
years the last one was Bridget Jones in
2013 it's really encouraging that people
are buying physical fiction it's not all
ebook because ebook really hit fiction
hard in terms of physical I mean David
Walliams it's an absolute phenomenon is
he I mean this book is how does it
compare with some of his previous ones
well so David
Williams was number one last year with
the Midnight gang and actually the
Christmas week it sold more but
year-to-date since released bad dad has
sold 10,000 more than the midnight gang
last year so David Williams and
children's appetite for funny fiction is
just going from strength to strength
how important is Christmas for
booksellers it's I mean it's a key time
because it is a time of people buying
gifts for people but such an amazing
gift and so if we look at the overall
revenue for the year the kind of
four-week Christmas period accounts for
nearly 1/5 of the whole period and that
goes up for nonfiction again so it's
it's so important then actually the
Christmas week sells a hundred thousand
more ISBNs that's individual different
types of books in the Christmas week
than the rest of the year so we're
buying more varied product at this time
as well very briefly hazel I mean is
this comparable in any way to the
cinemas so do the publishers always put
their big blockbusters out for the
Christmas holidays rather like we saw
Disney do last week with Star Wars we
have a start to Christmas in the book
world called super Thursday and it's in
October and that's when we release more
books and it's almost starts right
Christmas is ready go out and buy these
great offerings we've got for you all
right
hazel Canyon for Nilsen book good to see
ya thanks for joining me